quiero entonces que profundicemos en
estos cambios que ha traído el actual
presidente Turco reyeta hiber dubán para
su país durante los diez años que ha
tenido como presidente y los diez
anteriores que tuvo como Primer Ministro
para eso nos acompaña nuestro cronista
especializado en todos los temas de
historia Álvaro Cordero Álvaro
bienvenido un placer tenerlo acá Muchas
gracias bueno ahora sí cuéntenos usted
que es el experto en esta materia de
Dónde surge la figura de erdoan y como
alguien que se demostraba como un líder
obrero en Estambul llega a ser el Primer
Ministro de Turquía bueno la figura de
erdogan empezó a tomar notoriedad a
finales del siglo XX él ya fue alcalde
de Estambul en esa época y bueno empezó
a surgir como una figura islamista en un
país que en esa época era conocido sobre
todo por su secularismo y bueno empezó a
ganar una serie de Seguidores a lo largo
de esos años hasta que llegaron las
elecciones de para Primer Ministro del
año 2003 en las que erdogan consiguió
articular una victoria bastante
sorprendente e histórica en ese momento
al ser el primer líder islamista que
consiguió una victoria en Turquía María
Clara hay que saber que durante las
primeras décadas y la bueno varias
décadas después de la fundación de
Turquía como estado Turquía se
caracterizó por seguir una corriente
ideológica llamada quemalismo fundada
por mustafake el fundador precisamente
del Estado Turco que se caracterizaba
por por varios puntos uno de ellos era
el secularismo estatal en todos los
ámbitos en todos los ámbitos públicos
también una fuerte presencia del estado
y una relativa cercanía hacia occidente
erdogan consigue plantarle cara a este
oficialismo que estaba ya muy desgastado
por varios años de gobierno en los que
se habían vivido situaciones bastante
controversiales como fue el terremoto de
Smith en el año 1999 que dejó 17.000
fallecidos y a miles de personas en la
calle y en esa campaña erdogan consiguió
articular ese voto de protesta
prometiendo mejoras en la situación del
Estado Turco con respecto a las
infraestructuras y recogiendo ese voto
de protesta como te decía María Clara de
Todos Los afectados en ese terremoto
además aparte de todo esto mantuvo un
discurso sorprendentemente europeísta
para sorprendentemente con lo que
escuchamos actualmente de erdogan me
refiero y bueno estas eran sus palabras
Al poco de ser elegido como Primer
Ministro en Turquía escuchemos
dado que la mayoría de la población
turca es musulmana el éxito Turco en el
proceso de la Unión Europea será un gran
ejemplo para otros países musulmanes y
mostrará como la democracia puede
convivir muy bien con el islam
como un gobierno muy claro y competente
usted Menciona un punto muy interesante
Álvaro que nuestros analistas ya estaban
planteando y es en este momento Como el
terremoto de febrero 2023 y como la
crisis económica le pueden jugar en
contra o no a erdoan para una posible
reelección y usted nos muestra en su
recuento histórico que cuando van fue
elegido Primer Ministro en 2003 dos de
los factores principales fueron el
terremoto de Smith de 1999
criticó ampliamente y que dejó muchos
menos muertos que los que el actual
terremoto Pues usted nos hablaba de
17.000 fallecidos Respecto a los más de
48.000 turcos que fallecieron en los más
recientes sismos y también en ese
momento había una crisis económica que
aún así era menos peor que la actual Le
quiero preguntar rápidamente atalia si
así como el terremoto de Smith y la
crisis económica jugaron a favor de
erdoan en 2003 el terremoto actual pueda
tener una un cambio en los comicios de
este año
yo creo que el terremoto sí puede tener
este puede como crear un un cambio
drástico porque aparte o sea la tragedia
sucedió muy recientemente y estamos
hablando de números muy severos muy muy
graves o sea es una tragedia No
únicamente a nivel nacional sino a
global yo creo entonces a pesar de que
Turquía dado que que ha tenido
relaciones muy fuertes bilaterales y
multilaterales con con el mundo exterior
y haya recibido muchísimo apoyo en
términos de la cooperación internacional
Pues muchas partes del del pueblo
han expresado su decepción ante las
instituciones
del gobierno Turco y también ante como
lo digo como antes cierta indiferencia
de algunos los que estaban o sea
supuestamente tenían que hacer más
puntuales o tenían que este ayudar de
una manera más eficaz Entonces es un
tema económico social de seguridad
humana y es es tan reciente que yo creo
que el día de hoy pues claramente
ha de estar teniendo como un impacto
Incluso respecto a la decisión política
que la gente está tomando Porque también
la región ha afectado pues ustedes
tocaron el tema de islamismo por ejemplo
y la región afecta pues son son zonas
bastante tradicionales y por ejemplo
estas regiones no fueron en los años
pasados caracterizados como como con una
tendencia hacia el partido opositor es
decir ggp o qué mal y pero ahorita a ver
qué cosas van a cambiar porque hay
muchos factores muchas empresas privadas
que no tenían buena estructura muchos
casos de Pues de seguridad en la región
el tema impuesto el terremoto hay mucho
misterio sobre el tema y pues claramente
esa tragedia puede impactar directamente
los resultados de esas elecciones porque
era una crisis humanitaria y le quiero
preguntar a Alejandro cómo pasamos de un
erdoan que criticaba la entonces lenta
respuesta gubernamental frente al
terremoto de Smith a un erdován
criticado por no responder con celeridad
a los terremotos de 2023 sí se vio un
debilitamiento de su imagen visto como
el un mal gestor de la crisis porque se
dijo existía alguna rencillas a nivel
espiritual a nivel religioso con algunos
de las personas que vivían ahí como
opositores de su partido y Por ende se
dijo la respuesta fue muy lento y de
otra parte se develó el tema de la
corrupción corrupción con muchas
empresas constructoras en las cuales no
contaban con los asentamientos ni con
las bases y eran temas de edificios
sociales también y eso afectó es una
Mella importante a tan poco tiempo como
vemos febrero y estamos en este caso de
mayo Y eso podría llevar Si se mantiene
la tendencia Posiblemente no a una
segunda vuelta pero sería lo que
llamamos nosotros un voto castigo como
se vio en el año a finales del 99 cuando
él se empieza a empoderar y en el año
2003 eso es un tema bastante a tener en
cuenta en ese aspecto bueno por ahora
ese voto castigo quizás se esté viendo
porque como ya lo habíamos visto verdán
no tiene la misma cantidad de votos que
había tenido en los dos comicios
presidenciales anteriores en 2014 y 2018
pero aún así se mantiene a la cabeza
actualmente el conteo de votos va en un
65,8%. Perdón continúa repuntando con
51,3 versus el 42,8 de qué mal kilich de
nuevo la diferencia baja una centésima y
aún es insuficiente para forzar a una
segunda ronda
Álvaro quiero regresar con usted porque
nuestros panelistas nos han mostrado una
visión mucho más mano dura de erdoan
pero cuando él asumió tal como usted ya
lo mencionó se mostraba más Europa y más
europeísta más abierto a occidente y no
tan islamista si bien tomó las banderas
del islamismo desde mucho antes de
asumir como Primer Ministro ha
endurecido su posición Cómo fueron esos
primeros cambios que introdujo erdogan
en el país bueno Estás en lo cierto
María Clara de hecho Durante los
primeros años prácticamente nadie en el
mundo cuestionaba el talante democrático
de erdogan en su gobierno y bueno estos
primeros cambios fueron visibles en un
inicio Pero no eran tan profundos como
los que más tarde se verían durante sus
gobiernos por ejemplo obviamente dentro
de su talante islamista priorización
priorizó un trato más favorable al islam
e inició una serie de reformas como
podría ser el hecho de que las mujeres
podían aparecer con velo en espacios
públicos de una forma mucho más libre
que en periodos anteriores sobre todo en
espacios públicos como te decía
universidades y también pues se empezó
una serie de el inicio de una serie de
construcciones de mezquitas y de
priorizaciones hacia hacia el islam que
desde luego tenían el objetivo de
favorecer o de concientizar de hacer más
contentos a sus seguidores más
conservadores de
la espada de los espacios más Rurales la
imagen que se empezó a fabricar erdogan
era la de un buen musulmán que venía de
origen es humildes Y que desde luego la
clase trabajadora de provincias y de
espacios Rurales como te comentaba
apoyaba con con bastante fuerza
además de todo esto
lo que deberíamos de destacar de estos
primeros años y que desde luego le
hicieron clave del éxito durante las
siguientes elecciones en el año 2007
para la reelección de Primer Ministro y
en el año 2011 es lo que antes ha
comentado en que es el éxito económico
que tuvo erdogan durante esos primeros
años a través de una liberalización de
empresas y una serie de fomento hacia
hacia el crecimiento de la economía
Estatal que desde luego fueron
fundamental para que el nivel de vida de
los turcos aumentara y que erdogan fuera
ha sido hubiese sido reelegido
sucesivamente como sucedió en estos años
pero bueno entonces cómo pasamos de la
imagen de un erdoan buen musulmán de
orígenes populares europeísta
democrático y además con un gran éxito
económico en qué momento comenzó a tener
tintes autoritarios en tener más
injerencias sobre el Banco Central a
comenzar a convertir iconos por ejemplo
del catolicismo en mezquitas Cuando
comenzó Este cambio de deriva bueno hubo
dos puntos importantes en este en este
proceso el primero que podríamos
considerar fueron las protestas en el y
de Estambul en el año 2013 fue unas
protestas que surgieron de forma
espontánea entre la población de esta
ciudad turca debido a que querían hacer
una construcción en este emblemático
parque y la gente los vecinos se
opusieron Pero esto de género en una
protesta contra el gobierno que fue
respondida por parte del Estado con
bastante represión especialmente contra
manifestantes que eran de una edad joven
eran eran estudiantes en muchos de los
casos y que tenían un discurso bastante
crítico con el tradicionalismo que
defendía erdogan este fue el primer
punto y desde luego el segundo punto que
fue clave fue el intento de golpe de
estado que sufrió erdogan en el año 2016
Por una parte de su ejército durante
estos días fueron apenas unos días se
contabilizaron varios cientos de muertos
y bueno el estado acusó A un teólogo
llamado fetulagulén que era un antiguo
Aliado de erdogan de estar detrás de
toda entona golpista pero desde luego
Aunque erdogan sobrevivió al golpe de
estado lo que sirvió este evento fue
para que el mandatario que ya por
Entonces era presidente ya había dejado
de ser el Primer Ministro
aumentará y concentrara más sus poderes
en su persona y fuera la excusa perfecta
para que estos poderes aumentaran y
precisamente ese aumento del poder presi
dencialmente respecto al poder
parlamentario se vio Con el referendo
que impulsó erdoan para cambiar puntos
claves de la Constitución turca a partir
de 2017 cuáles fueron esos cambios
Álvaro desde luego este referendo es
clave de hecho obtuvo el apoyo del 51,4%
de los votos un margen relativamente
estrecho y bueno este referendo los
cambios que incluían él consistían en la
creación de una república
presidencialista que dejaría que dejaría
atrás la república parlamentaria que
había en Turquía hasta hasta ese momento
además garantizaba Un aumento del Poder
del jefe del Estado Turco Que obviamente
era erdogan y reducía El poder del
parlamento Turco de todos los puntos que
se votaron el más importante quizás sea
la capacidad la potestad de erdogan para
elegir a la mitad de los jueces del
tribunal constitucional de Turquía algo
que le hacía tener un poder súper
importante muy importante en en el
panorama judicial y además de todo ello
los mandatos pasaban de ser de cuatro
años a cinco años algo que le permitía
pues tener un periodo más en el poder si
después de ser elegido a quienes están
conectando con nosotros a esta hora les
recuerdo que estamos en un cubrimiento
especial sobre las elecciones generales
que Se realizaron este domingo en
Turquía para elegir al nuevo presidente
y para cambiar los 600 miembros de la
asamblea nacional estamos haciendo un
recuento de Por qué importan estos
comicios de Cuál es el papel y más
adelante veremos Cuál es el papel del
líder opositor opositor Qué mal kirich
darolo que Podría quizás dar la sorpresa
Thalia quiero volver con usted porque
usted es de nacionalidad turca y Quiero
preguntarle cómo vivió usted la reformas
constitucionales de 2017 de las que nos
habla nuestro cronista Álvaro Cordero y
qué tan determinante fue para el cambio
de rumbo de erdoan desde una posición
quizás más democrática a unos tintes más
autocráticos
Pues sí es bastante interesante aquí
todo lo que plantean y pues María clara
recalcar que pues yo en estos momentos
me encontraba en México entonces de
todos modos mis comentarios van a ser de
fuera pero pues como ciudadana turca sí
te puedo decir y asegurar de que este
cambio generó muchísima diversidad de
opinión incluso me acuerdo que antes de
ese referéndum como que surgió un una
bipolaridad muy
radical dentro de la misma población
civil turca entonces justo estamos
hablando de esos momentos donde los
seguidores vuelven ser más fanático y
los opositores vuelven ser más más vamos
a decir como más apasionados en su
misión de criticar y también yo creo que
ese cambio genera muchísima
personalización incluso figuras de culto
a la persona en términos o Los
Seguidores
y viendo a los opositores Pues también
generó muchísima bipolaridad y una pues
segregación muy fuerte entre la misma
población turca porque claro como
mencionan en un inicio pues ciertos
puntos no eran tan tan extremos pero
Turquía Pues también dado por su
geografía turquesa es un país que
siempre va a tener retos en diferentes
lados porque por su geoestrategia llevas
muchos temas al mismo tiempo está el
tema de refugiados están ciertos temas
nacionales como el tema de chipre
está están los temas de Siria están sus
relaciones con Rusia y eso es como como
había mencionado antes como destino de
Turquía pero encima de todo cuando pasen
incidentes como el atento de golpe del
estado por ejemplo la tragedia de
terremoto pues son son momentos de
crisis Entonces yo creo que en esos
momentos de crisis
aprovechándose para empoderarse su
persona
carismática como líder más bien como
como él quería ser percibido y en cierto
población sí funcionan porque tantos
años también vuelven ser en la costumbre
a nivel nacional y eso no cambia el
hecho de que él sigue representando
intereses y normas de cierta población
pero usted nos contaba inicialmente que
este referendo Se recibió con una gran
División y así también lo mostraron los
resultados como bien lo decía Álvaro el
51% de los votos 51 como 4 aprobaron el
referendo esto es poco más de la mitad
de los votantes y usted también
mencionaba que aún así erdoan aprovechó
las crisis y supo catapultarse como una
figura carismática en Turquía y que uno
de sus grandes fuertes ha sido la
estrategia geopolítica que ha tenido en
medio oriente en África y sobre todo
cómo ha manejado su relación con Rusia
donde es rival o contrario en guerras
por ejemplo como Siria y Libia y ahora
intenta hacer de mediador en la Guerra
de Ucrania y Rusia Álvaro quiero
regresar con usted porque precisamente
usted nos puede contar a pesar de todos
estos traspiés en la política interna
Cómo ha sido el papel de erdoan en las
relaciones exteriores Bueno pues lo
cierto Es que en estos años algo
innegable es que erdogan ha convertido a
Turquía en una especie de potencia
regional en la zona sobre todo de medio
oriente y África y sobre todo la ha
conseguido a través de una estrategia
que tiene un carisma ambivalente y
también inteligente por parte de erdogan
por ejemplo Turquía ha entrado de lleno
en algunos conflictos que le interesaban
como era la guerra civil Siria en favor
de los Rebeldes al norte del país la
guerra civil Libia o el conflicto que ha
habido en el año 2020 en nagorno caravag
en Favor de hacer vayán pero también por
otro lado se ha mostrado como un actor
mediador en otros conflictos como es el
actual que se está viviendo en Ucrania
donde Turquía ha sido fundamental en
acuerdos como el de la exportación de
grano lo que desde luego está claro es
que Turquía en los últimos 10 años de 13
15 10 años paralelamente estos procesos
internos que hemos comentado
anteriormente se ha ido alejando
progresivamente de occidente todo ello
sin salir de otros de Grandes alianzas
como pueden ser la otan hay que recordar
que Turquía es el segundo mayor
aportador después de Estados Unidos a
esta organización militar pero
paralelamente a seguir ligados a esta
organización se ha ido acercando a otras
potencias emergentes con tintes
autoritarios también como puede ser
Rusia o china
todo esto además ha ido ligado a cierta
desafección especialmente contra
Bruselas contra la Unión Europea contra
la Unión Europea Perdón ha habido
bastantes tensiones en los últimos años
especialmente después de un evento muy
importante
como fue la crisis de migrantes del año
2015 durante esta crisis millones de
personas salieron hacia hacia Europa
precisamente por la gran inestabilidad
que había en algunas naciones de medio
oriente y de África y Europa la solución
que tuvo ante esto después de estos
momentos de crisis fue convertir a
Turquía en una especie de estado tapón
para estos flujos migratorios a cambio
obviamente de grandes cantidades de
dinero un acuerdo que desde luego ha
sido muy controversial pero que desde
luego también ha servido para que
erdogan sepa que tiene cierto poder
sobre Bruselas Por qué Porque es
consciente de que si Abre esos flujos
migratorios desde luego es un arma de
presión contra la Unión Europea es un
arma que en algunas ocasiones utilizado
en base a amenazas desde luego Bruselas
depende de las del talante y de las
circunstancias que quiera conducir
erdogan en este aspecto migratorio y no
solo le ha no solo las ha utilizado sino
que también le han funcionado Bruselas
sin duda alguna siente esta gran presión
y por el otro lado esto también ha
dejado congelado el proceso en el que
Turquía buscaba hacer parte del bloque
de los 27 sin embargo usted nos explica
todo el repunte que ha tenido Turquía y
que se ha logrado posicionar cada vez
más como una potencia regional en medio
de todo esto Álvaro En qué contexto
llegamos a las elecciones generales de
este domingo pues rogán llegan una
situación un poco complicada Es cierto
que bueno como vemos en los sondeos de
momento va primero pero el apoyo que ha
tenido parece que puede decrecer hay que
recordar que en las dos elecciones
presidenciales anteriores que ha tenido
erdogan super 50% en ambas y bueno se
puede dar un resultado algo más ajustado
en esta en esta ocasión las claves de
esto desde luego basan en varios
aspectos Pero hay dos fundamentales el
primero es otra vez el tema de la
economía la inflación en Turquía está es
galopante ya no tiene nada que ver el
milagro económico Turco que se vivieron
en los primeros años de del gobierno de
erdogan estamos en otra situación muy
diferente Que desde luego está golpeando
a la población más más pobre más de
clase trabajadora que en muchos casos ha
sido quien más ha votado por erdogan en
esas elecciones anteriores donde tuvo
éxito y luego por supuesto está el
terremoto de febrero de este año que ha
golpeado la credibilidad de erdogan de
forma bastante fuerte precisamente por
Cómo llegó al poder erdogan como
comenzábamos esta intervención él llegó
al poder en el año 2003 gracias a un
discurso muy crítico con el estado y con
el el establecimiento de ese momento por
su por su por su desarrollo de las
ayudas con respecto al terremoto Disney
del año 1999 y se ha visto que después
de este terremoto no se habían acometido
todos esos cambios que erdogan prometió
en esas elecciones y luego
posteriormente cambios en la en la
construcción de los edificios en las
infraestructuras y demás además estas
regiones que han sido tan golpeadas por
el terremoto históricamente habían sido
bastiones erdoganistas bastante fuertes
donde haya conseguido victorias muy
holgadas Entonces está ahora por ver si
en estas regiones erdogan va a conseguir
imponerse otra vez de forma tan Clara o
no que es la gran pregunta que trae en
estos comicios álvaros Gracias por
acompañarnos Muchas gracias a ti María
Clara